this morning 11 members of a far-right
extremist group the oath keepers are
charged with conspiracy to overthrow the
u.s government the justice department
accuses the suspects of creating a
battle plan for last year's assault on
the capital these are by far the most
serious charges today in connection with
the january 6 riot senior investigative
correspondent katherine herridge has the
story
more than a thousand miles from
washington d.c federal agents arrested
stuart rose the leader and founder of
the oath keepers at his home in texas
the newly unsealed indictment marks the
first time rhodes a former army
paratrooper and edward vallejo of
arizona are charged in connection with
the riots rhodes and 10 co-defendants
are accused of a months-long conspiracy
to oppose by force the transfer of
presidential power thomas o'connor was
an fbi agent with the joint terrorism
task force for almost 23 years we never
brought a charge of sedition it is
extremely serious it is the highest
level
on january 6 prosecutors allege the oath
keepers marched in two stack formations
to breach the building
once inside it's alleged one team headed
toward the senate chamber and a second
team went in search of house speaker
pelosi
outside the capitol prosecutors say the
oath keepers had a quick reaction force
prepared to rapidly transport firearms
and other weapons
as the violence unfolded rhodes
allegedly expressed his frustration with
the trump administration via encrypted
messaging pence is doing nothing as i
predicted all i see trump doing is
complaining i see no intent by him to do
anything so the patriots are taking it
into their own hands they've had enough
roses due in a texas court later today a
conviction could bring up to 20 years in
prison contacted by cbs news one of his
lawyers questioned whether the
indictment contains new significant
evidence against his client
gail
all right catherine thank you very much